boa noite boa noite boa noite bebê
eita oi meu nome é o índice tem 1 milhão
e 42 mil de óleo de soja no acumulado e
não esquece brincar em gostei logo no
começou e se inscreve no canal e muita
gente que me assiste não é escrita com
sabendo porque tem os números provado no
google e aí galera que assistiu a nada
de bom vocês são agora do de trinta e
sete da manhã em rio tons estados unidos
e hoje eu tenho pra outra cidade já
fazer outro show porque você não está
dormindo porque não tem como né amor mo
né tá parecendo menos 20 crianças
dizendo que as crianças é coisa ruim s
coisa se cortar eu ficar ameno um irmão
o irmão o mundo tá bagunçado porque
fantasma foi vídeo inédita vídeo imposta
a obra de quem tudo ser um monstro ser
humano quando quer perturbar lhe
perturba
já no baixo perto barzotto em perturbar
as crianã as crianças o bichinho está
assistindo o vídeo olha gente aqui a
gente pegar a comidinha e vamos coisa
qaeda do boneco do cão espanto menino em
paço do diã se tremendo e e e
traumatismo que eu lembro costinha kaká
novela o beijo do vampiro mancha é hoje
eu tô meio do tato gabus mendes a cuba
afogados nem nato da capo gado mendes a
tatoo tatu tudo acabado o treinador você
num cargo
você nunca gostou de mim o cm joão os
ele jogou fora esse ato aqui tá bom é o
tato gabus mesmo a chuva esse cara
transforma em vampiro ficava era criança
de shaker eo tato também unila canela
meta lá nem eu só tô aqui
o ney latorraca ney latorraca [ __ ]
jurava que era ney latorraca na época o
caso tinha caio castro é caioca mostrou
enfim aí venham boneca e aparece no meio
bicho e só de outra criança cara da obra
de gente as pessoas faz papá fazer as
crianças fazer o mal aí perto a vida das
ruas
criança e dos pais a mãe que não tem um
menu de sus e que pensava assim eu vou
botar o nome na frente do tablet
entendeu o down play nesta merda deste
evento a ver se eu consigo alguns a e
paz haiti e domínio de sucesso não tem
mar vamos fazer uma refeição decente no
par mais vendeu que agora tem vitória no
domingo de anita existindo que aí já
essa faca já querendo aprender o
malabares amigo ou mudou recheio deputar
e vê lo aí faz a boneca parecem dizendo
a criança
minha nossa senhora é o deus do céu
verdasco também quando era criança só
que tipo assim quando era criança não
tinha muito o que ver para você tem medo
você tinha medo porque o pessoal dizia e
você imaginava e tudo que você imaginava
era pior talvez do que o povo dizia que
tinha medo de saber que ela traz aqui
tinha medo do chupa-cabra eu amigo
porque não tinha foto do chupa cabra não
tinha vídeos pra cá quem dizer o povo aí
eu vi em culpa só de flandes que viu
frio acaba sujo por cabo ou tessália não
viu e como era ele
meu amigo não quer saber de ficar dois
nunca tinha visto não sabe onde é que
tinha não sabia onde é não sabia que é
que fazia um chupa cabra e para ver como
eles até mesmo porque eu tinha uma cabra
eu não sou cabo que se o chupa-cabra
chupa cabra na fazenda eu vou nem tinha
cabe o nome influencia por exemplo bicho
papão tinha medo do bicho papão o do
meio bicho papão é bicho-papão né agora
chupa-cabra eu só fiquei com medo do
bicho papão quando eu vi no harry potter
disse que o harry potter o bicho papão
virava tudo aquilo que eu sei mas tinha
medo de ver aí meu amigo morrer de metal
para o bicho papões se transformando meu
pai transando aiea um trauma na vida da
criança
imagina você é o bicho papão não viu o
show não faz isso comigo velho não não
pára por aí
apaga não tinha medo do cara e eu tinha
medo
webb a água depois tá aí gemendo
planejar não sabe o que é saber a cor
que eu tinha um medo do cara e até hoje
ainda tenho um pouquinho só fechar que
ela continue to tatame abertinho sinto
que meu amigo para ver como é que a
cabeça da gente faz agora que o olho
assim fico procurando coisa ver no fim e
aí você vê usando armadilhas essencial
de todo ser humano contra monstros ou é
só quem fala livro couro nappa para o
monstro não vê otário o cara tá aqui
domingo em boa hora de muita gente ali
atrás do cabo é aí ele é fofo um pega
brodheim eu tinha medo de mais queria
ver o time na goleada botar aquela
música pra mim mistérios da meia noite
que voa longe que você nunca não sabe
nunca vai ficar quem é quem foi um show
você vê o coração da criança acelerar
assim são botar essa música pé de mim eu
pular no quadro fifa cabra macho ou
juizinho assim de criança meu cérebro
exibe ficar doido que ficar quente agora
quem vai quem fica tem a quem foi a
equipe orava em períodos de o lobisomem
que fosse um homem eu apanhava tanto meu
pai seu pai o senhor é um homem seu nome
exame não né pai é pai quem é que vai
querer ver quem vai querer foi minha mãe
usava isso como castigo na rua lourenço
desenrolava lousa não era de óleo zé
ramalho meu amigo eu lavava louça lavada
e não queria julgar deixava lá em cima
escorrendo chegar e dizer quem vai e
quem fica quem vai enxugar enxuga
guardado numa bonita tão grande que
chamou tivesse lá botar para jogar
também como julgados aqui como disse
josé ramalho cavini viu daniel agora
como eu queria que você comentasse aqui
em baixo do que se tinha medo quando era
criança eu espero que tenha gostado que
eu aparecer por aqui e clique no botão
gostei aí não esquece e clicar em gostei
que se você não cuidar em 2 t e um chupa
com vai aparecer de você se inscreve no
meu canal cara se você na escrita em
você tem pelo instagram pelo twitter e
pelo facebook se inscreve no canal é
muito importante estou gravando muita
coisa pelo mundo eu pulei um lago a 2
grau na noruega eu não tenho sumô do
japão não conhecia o fado em portugal
fazendo tanta coisa [ __ ] pelo mundo eu
quero que você assiste então se inscreve
no canal para não perder
tamo junto é nóis valeu epr